the role of the police and protesters
now very much under the microscope in
Hong Kong
they've been violent arrests and what
appeared to be indiscriminate beatings
they make unsettling viewing with
repeated claims of police brutality and
sexual intimidation the arrest of key
pro-democracy activists including Agnes
Chau and Joshua Wong days ago on the eve
of Evander Ali has incensed Hong Kong as
we met Agnes Chau who's still a student
away from the crowds she now faces jail
charged with taking part in an
unauthorized demonstration after I was
arrested in the police station during
the attack the Polish hack I was also
forced to take off my trousers and my
you know my my my charges are not
something about you know hiding drugs or
anything like that my much Hajus is
getting forth in protests sounds pretty
intimidating though yes and and I
believe that these kinds of sexual
harassment or this kind of violence
attack from the police would continue in
this movement or even in the future Hong
Kong because the Hong Kong government
keeps on avoiding their responsibility
to to have independent investigation the
police have frequently used pepper spray
human rights groups want an
investigation into actions like these
the firing of teargas indoors Amnesty
International called these horrifying
and unlawful acts and Hong Kong's chief
executive appears tortured by what's
going on in her country in an audio
recording which has just emerged she's
heard telling businesspeople she's
caused unforgiveable havoc the recent
movement of Chinese troops on the
streets of Hong Kong has raised worries
that Beijing might use their army the
PLA to crush the protests Carrie Lam
insists not but these images have
disturbed many around the world
the police are facing increasingly
violent protesters who are using petrol
bombs more and more frequently they're
building barricades and fires and
indulging in wanton vandalism we managed
to persuade some of the hardcore
protesters to speak to us I think I
compared to the brutal force of her
government
afforable I think for this stage certain
violence is needed they work people with
no reason the customers lower zone and
they are not they are not police anymore
I think because Paul this is for
protective evil the gulf between the two
sides
seems as far away as ever Alex Crawford
Sky News Hong Kong